hi today we're looking at short cut
learning in deep neural networks by a
number of authors from the University of
Tubingen the Max Planck Research Center
and the University of Toronto so I'm not
gonna read all of them but all of them
are either joint first authors or joint
senior authors I just what is this like
there is just a team of people who did
this work together this whole I have a
store I don't have a store I have across
whatever ok sorry bit of a rant alright
so this this paper discusses what they
call short cut learning and they
actually they don't in like propose
something new here they discuss this
phenomenon and they try to link several
things together under the name of short
cut learning which they claim is a is a
problem in current deep learning and
they discuss why it happens and what can
be done about it
and I just want to jump into this
example real quick right so in this case
you can see you have a training set of
images and the training set is these
four images here along with these labels
and also these four images along with
the these labels right so you can think
you can train a machine learning model
let's say you have a bunch of those and
then you're gonna test them on the iid
test set right on this test set and what
you'll find is that if you let a human
do this task right the the human would
give this an a this an a this a B and
this B which is what you can think of is
probably what a human would do is like
these are the stars and these are the
moons right and the human would see the
stars and the humans would see the moons
and if you do this by the neural network
also you'd get the labels a a b and b
and now you go
this out of distribution test it and
we'll go over it why that is out of
distribution in a second again you'll
see that the human will classify this as
the A's because it has the stars and
these as bees but the neural network
will classify these as bees and these as
ace so I'm not saying this is what's
gonna happen every time but imagine that
happens and this is a conceivable a
conceivable situation and you can think
of what happens here so you see in the
training set all of the stars were
either and the bottom left right or in
the top right of the image
where if I whereas the moons were either
in the bottom right or the top left
right you see that so the neural network
might have learned that this is moon and
this is moon and this is star and this
is star or and then if it applies that
rule to this new test set right then you
can see that will classify these as
moons and these as stars which is
incorrect so this might happen for
example if the person that wrote the
generator for the for the data set for
some reason it it produced only data
here that had this property of the
bottom left top right being a star and
otherwise being a moon so what generally
happens if we do machine learning test
set is we collect a data set a big data
set but we collect it in a single pass
right so this is our data set and what
we'll do then is we'll split it right
into a fairly large tray and maybe a bit
of a smaller test
set right but this it's important that
we first collect the data and then
second we randomly split it now
this out of distribution test set what
that might be
is that might be a second person right
so this was done in a first step but
then later right a person collects
another bunch of data so this is data
two and and they think it's it should be
the same as this data but then you apply
the the the classifier that you learned
and train and test you apply that here
right so what is different in this case
is the data collection process that
happens beforehand right so somewhere
here is the real world I'm gonna draw
the real world this is it's a globe this
is the real world and you draw datasets
from the real world and you draw this
data set first and then you split it in
train and test and then you draw this
data set second so the second data set
has a fundamentally is a different
sample of data and this data whereas
these train and tests you can think of
them they're closer together then these
two data sets are here I think that's
that's all that's kind of intuitive so
what we usually do is we terrain here
and then we evaluate on the test set
right but the training tests that they
they've just they're just like randomly
split versions of the same data set and
that means that if there is some kind of
bias in the training set it's probably
also in the test set like we saw here
with the moons right so this training
set is this this test set is this and
both have this this moon moon star star
property because that was introduced so
this pattern here by accident in this
case was introduced when the data was
Purdue
right whereas the OOD test set now is
maybe a second person writing their own
generator that doesn't have this
property and then that will lead to this
data and of course since we trained on
the this tape trainer and evaluate on
iid data this is now the iid assumption
and the evaluate on the iid test data
we're gonna do fairly well with our you
know crooked decision rule because it
has the same bias but then if we once we
evaluate on the on the out of
distribution data then we we will fail
right because now this doesn't have this
in this bias in it right this this is
not here so shortcut learning refers to
the phenomenon that there might be
features in the training set that the
model starts to learn such such that it
learns something else that we want it to
learn right we want it to learn the
shape here but it learns something else
it learns the position and usually these
things will not be recognized by
generalizing to this test set right
because the tests at being an iid split
from the same training set will have
these same biases and therefore they
will only become apparent once we do out
of distribution generalization
evaluation so this is shortcut learning
and this paper goes into the origins and
kind of descriptions of this and while I
think this is a good approach and paper
and it says many correct things I think
the framing is a bit off at times and
welcomed through it so first of all they
say they give some examples in
biological neural networks so they have
this one example where they have a rat
and the rat learned to navigate a
complex maze right based on color
differences of the walls and this was
surprising because rats don't really
have color vision or it was kind of
known that rats don't have super good
color vision so it was very surprising
and then they discovered that the rats
did actually not use the visual system
at all they simply discriminated the
colors by the odor of the color of paint
right so if you painted the wall book
red or blue that smelled differently and
the rats could smell it
once they controlled for the smell the
remarkable color discrimination ability
disappeared right so the second example
they give here is so Alice loves history
and Alice had spent weeks immersing
herself in the world of Hannibal and his
exploits in the Roman Empire and now the
exam questions are just like how many
elephants did Hannibal employ in his
army so the exam question or a
multiple-choice not focus on
understanding and bob had just learned
it by heart and is now doing much better
than Alice who has actually understood
the topic in right so they give this as
examples of shortcut learning where the
model learns something that we don't
intend it to do right all right and I I
think this is the crucial point right
the model learns something that we don't
intend it to do and so here and this
seems this this this might be pretty
clear to when you observe it but what do
we want we want we want shape and the
model learns
something else right just something else
and the crucial part here and I think
this paper isn't putting that much as
much emphasis as it deserves is the two
words we and want so my my basically my
answer to this is first of all the word
want we want shape and my answer my
comment to this is you can't you can
formulate that you can't formulate it
this this is very crucial and I think
the the paper it almost ignores this
point you cannot formulate what it means
to classify things by shape and this
seems so oblivious to us because we're
so used to it as humans right we were
just like oh it's just used the shape
right this is the shape right but you
cannot you cannot program a computer to
do this that's why we use deep learning
in the first place right because we have
no freaking idea how to program an
algorithm that extracts the shape of
something it might be possible for like
a star in the moon but not for a cat or
a car or anything right so you cannot
formulate your objective that's the
problem right and and it's easy to then
say oh the model doesn't do what we want
it to do it's like you can't even
formulate what you want it to do in a
precise way so basically all all you're
you're saying here what you're saying
here is I'll train a shape classifier
right once you've gone through this
process of training and evaluating you
you say now I have a now I have a shape
classifier right say say you haven't you
had
done this ood evaluation you've gone
through this and used you know how you
now claim you proclaim I have trained a
shape classifier no no you have trained
something that given the entire process
of how you create your data can classify
these two images right so at here is
your generator this is your little
program that you wrote to produce these
images and your generator assigns either
the star rec at random it produces these
things the star or the moon it does
these two things and then it creates the
image from it and that will give you
your data set right what you have
trained is not a shape classifier what
you have trained is a classifier that
can distinguish data that comes from
that this data generation process right
the entire notion of calling it a shape
classifier is because you as a human
have thought of shape when you
programmed this generator right when you
collected the data set that's what you
thought of but this isn't the case you
can't call it a shape classifier just
because you like this is what your
intent was you have a classifier that
that classifies images from this
particular data generation process and
you can't actually formulate a shape
classifier right ok the second word is
we we sorry we
humans right we want shape classifier
now I've I've said this before and this
is very much refers back to the to for
example the paper about the contrast
sets in NLP and so on humans have
grounded knowledge right
humans humans have grounding this is
very important here grounding means that
the humans live in a world of physics
and culture
sorry physics and culture and the need
for food biology humans live in this
world and this this generated our brain
right so what that means is that humans
live in a world of objects and of of
people sorry of people and of being
eaten right being eaten or needing to
eat food right humans litt grew up and
live in this world your brain was
literally structured according to these
things and thus we understand everything
with an eye to this grounded knowledge
of reality where there is such a thing
as objects now if you have image net and
you train a classifier for objects right
this is what I find so crazy right and
in the you know we collect this thing
and there's a car and you say that's a
car right you know this is a car because
there is an object of a car and and and
but the the neural network is not does
not have a bias for object in a real
Network simply sees these pixels
same here what you will do immediately
here is you'll recognize the object of
the star right you will transform this
into a 3d scene right into a 3d cube
where you are here watching in 3d space
and there is this star object somewhere
here right and then you understand that
the star could move around then it would
still be the same star but that's
because you have the inherent bias of
there being objects and shape for
example the word shape is nothing more
than a property of an object and the
neural net or simply do not have a
inherent bias for objects right or
people or intent or what it needs to eat
right this this becomes a super super
obvious if you ever try to solve for
example a a jigsaw puzzle you know like
these these things here I'm terrible at
this if you solve this on its head right
say this has like a face on it and you
try to solve it like this and you try to
solve it on its head like try it you'll
feel it's the same task you simply need
to match the border shapes right and you
need to make sure that the lines are
continuous of the picture it becomes so
much harder just because you have this
brain and so that is my my entire
criticism it will it will pull through
this entire paper and we'll go through
it for now relatively quickly because
we've already like touched touched on it
keep in mind this is my commentary on it
this is not superior superior knowledge
or something that's just me all right
so what they do is they have this
taxonomy of decision rules that they
they point out what they're saying
okay you're you these there's a set of
all possible decision rules right and
this is the this is the outer set here
all possible decision rules that one
could think of to discriminate data and
let's say we will talk about images here
right - to discriminate images most of
them will just be crap and these will be
using these uninformative features what
they say but then there are some
decision rules that perform well on
training data right this is this big
circle here right so that there are some
decision rules that perform well on the
training set and they call these
overfitting features so these are all
the features that perform well on the
training set only on the training sets
are the overfitting features but to me
it's it's a bit unclear I think they
only call this band the overfitting
features but they call the entire circle
the all possible training solutions any
case so there are decision rules that
perform well on the training set but
some of them are overfitting as you know
that problem right then the next circle
inside of that are all decision rules
that perform well on the training set
and the iid test set and this would be
our our location classifier from before
would fall into this category right and
now there these are still a much larger
set as you see here as this inside set
of the intended solution performs well
on training set ID and all relevant out
of distribution test sets and then they
draw this in here the out of
distribution test sets are subsets of
the iid test set already sorry the
solutions that work on the OD test set
are subsets of the solutions that work
well on the iid test set I don't have a
problem with this characterization of
decision rules right here is
specifically these are decision rules
what I have a
of characterization with is the fact
that you cannot specify what the
intended solution is you cannot and
therefore this diagram I think is
misleading because you have ultimately
you have no idea where this dot is right
you you can't you can't specify it
beforehand
you can't even specify the rules how you
get there all you can do is give better
data and they kind of advocate for this
here with these ood test sets but again
I think when they say all relevant out
of distribution test sets I'm a bit I'm
a bit wary because they they suggest
this as one of the measures to assess
whether or not a model has learned these
shortcut rules is to measure its
performance on out of distribution test
sets and this is very much like the
contrast sets in in in the NLP but I I
think actually this is a pretty pretty
pretty pretty bad solution in most cases
and let me explain why so if we go back
to here right what we saw is that these
these discrepancy it comes about because
here from the real world
we produce the data in a very specific
form right and then this other out of
distribution test that is produced in a
slightly different form right now what
you can think of this is if you look at
your cost function that you train right
what usually say is my cost function is
some sort of a loss for my data points
and my labels right but this is often
left out I mean you write it in your
introductory classes what is important
is that this is an expected loss that
you're minimizing here over a data
distribution right over X and why
sampled from a particular data
distribution now when you talk about
this this out of distribution
classifiers what you'll have is you'll
have a slightly different data
distribution D Prime right so but if you
simply have one out of distribution
saying think of this as the contrast set
right if you haven't seen the video
about contrast sets
it's basically an handcrafted out of
distribution test set my problem with
this it's just one it's one it's a
single one and I I think even if you try
ten of them ten of those sets you won't
even get close to a true measure because
so the cool thing about an iid test set
is at least it is precisely the same
distribution right so it kind of gives
you an unbiased number that for this
particular data generation pipeline you
get this number if you evaluate on it
out of distribution test set you now
have two effects you first have this
generalization effect and you have the
effect of having produced this in a
different fashion here but you only have
one of them what you would like to do is
you would what you would like to assess
is your loss of x and y in expectation
with x and y coming from data in
expectation I mean difficult in
expectation with your data distribution
coming from all possible data
distributions in the real world right
that's what you would like to to say to
do now if you only have a single
contrast set it is akin you can think of
what if
like how how well how well of a machine
learning engineer would I be if my test
set here only had one sample right so so
I give you a train and the test set and
I'm saying your performance will be if I
make a cattle challenge and I say your
performance will be evaluated on this
one single sample test set right that's
basically what you're doing if you have
a single ood test set is you're saying
I'm going to give you one out of
distribution data set that I have biased
in one particular way right and will
measure how well you capture our intent
right our shape classifier intent will
measure how well you capture that using
this one single out of distribution
thing I think what that will do is read
you say I want to approximate this by a
sum of I equals 1 to 1 that will just
pump the variance beyond what beyond any
reasonable meaning that the outcoming
number will we'll be able to give you
what you'd have to do is you'd have to
have this entire process and sample
terrain and test sets according to this
day or at least test sets according to
this data distribution this underlying
data distribution which you have no clue
what it is because if you could specify
this directly you could get the solution
for free right if you could specify the
underlying mechanism you could you you
would already know the solution you
wouldn't need machine learning so I
think the model puts like way too little
emphasis sorry the paper puts a bit too
little emphasis suffice to say they with
their taxonomy they can say if you use
for example only the overfitting
features right
then you will do well on the training
set but not on the I ID and OD test set
if you use the intended features again
intended no one knows what that is then
we can specify it you'll do well on all
the or OD test sets if you use the
shortcut features you will do well on
the training and iid test set but not on
the ood test this is valid right I'm not
discrediting this paper here and they do
allude to a lot of the things I'm saying
but not not all and I don't think they
frame it correctly so they ask shortcuts
where do they come from and they say a
lot of the things that I've been saying
here but for example they ask what makes
a cow a cow and they give this example
here where they say familiar background
can be as important for recognition -
deep neural networks where the deep
neural networks will miss classify this
picture because they you used to seeing
a cow in grass now consider this in our
framework right if let's say this is an
image net classifier image net is not an
object classifier it is not right
that's what we say that's our intent but
what it is it is a classifier if you go
through the pipeline how do you generate
the data image net is a classifier of
naturally taking images right with a
certain camera cropped center cropped to
a particular object labeled by human
raters filtered in some capacity right
from Flickr and for that particular data
set we train a classifier it is not an
object classifier it is a classifier for
that and it doesn't has no clue of
objects so in fact and also what you
have to see is that the output isn't
even if the output is shape it isn't
shape it is actually probability of
shape right or probability of object or
probability of something right and it is
completely conceivable right
if it's not grass in the background it's
probably not as much a cow now I see the
problem here this is clearly a cow and
this is actually a conceivable natural
image but imagine a picture of the cow
oops on the moon right this is the moon
and here's the cow Moo this is terrible
a cow on the moon like who can fault the
neural network it it and I would say
that's not a cow either because in terms
of the data generation process if you
ask me
please classify this as a natural image
that has been taken buh-buh-buh-buh-buh
right I'm gonna say there's no way
there's a cow on the moon so I don't
know what this is but it is very
improbable that this is a cow right
because all the training examples I've
seen cow on grass so yeah so I mean they
do they do actually allude to this right
they they call this data set biases and
so on but I'm pretty sure that yet the
interpretation is just a bit off where
they say they descent the point of this
is like ah it's you know we want an
object classifier but this we want the
second I find even more kind of strange
is they say shortcuts from
discriminative learning and they allude
to this picture here and they ask what
makes a cat a cat and they basically
their argument is that the neural
networks they don't understand things
they just discriminate right they they
have these thousand classes and the
output layer this is the neural network
and they just need to discriminate so
they just need to learn what is
different from one class to the other
class and they will often rely on
features such as texture like here so
they rely on detection they classify
this as an
right so they say what makes a cat a cat
- standard en ends the example image on
the left clearly shows an elephant nor
the cat and again I agree if you tell me
this is data from naturally - taken
images with standard cameras right then
I will I will have two possibility I
will say is this a cat there's no way
that if you take anywhere in the
universe a picture with a like a phone
camera of anything of a cat it will look
like this no way it's just not possible
right however is it possible that there
is an elephant that as a skin fold
pattern by random chance elephant big
ears trunk as a skin fold pattern looks
like a cat that looks like the shape of
a cat yes that's possible so if you ask
me according to the data generation
process this is way more likely to be an
elephant than a cat right and and the
paper here make it makes it seem like it
is so obvious that this is a cat but
what do this standard stupid dnns think
it's an elephant nor the cat and the DNN
oh it's just looking at object text and
other local structures and nor that
shape right what we like what we wanted
to do and this this is I find just stop
calling things object classifiers if
there are not object classifiers that
classifier between images of a instead
of a data generation process if you want
them to be object classifiers make up
the data set that actually has different
objects but you can't specify that so
yeah and then they go into some sort of
adversarial examples and I find this to
be I also find this to be a bit maybe
not belonging here like
that where they say oh look here the DN
ends predicted guitar with high
certainty
again it's just a discriminator but this
this pattern why not
guitar if if you had to you know if you
had to get one of the thousand classes
out why it could this not be most likely
a guitar but I have a further problem
with this is I see I kind of see this in
so what what would you have is iid data
let's go with their taxonomy and say iid
data as from from the same generation
process and then there is o OD data now
I think there are a number of effects
here that they try to lump together with
this thing where they just say ooo D
data whenever my model doesn't work on
OD data it has learned a shortcut but it
is very very weird so first of all there
I would say the OD data you can probably
divide into what I call unnatural hourly
data let's say our task here is to build
an object an object to detect or
whatever that means for natural images
so then there's unnatural
ood data which which in here you'll find
something like adversarial examples
right adversarial examples are
constructed at least if you go by the
interpretation of Madhuri and the
adversarial examples are features not
bugs then you will go into the direction
of adversarial examples actually
constructed by combining features that
don't naturally go together so you'll
you'll get the low-frequency features of
a cat and add the high frequency for
example features of a dog so much with
this with this lambda factor here so
high that it to a DNN it looks like a
dog because it has many of the features
but to a human that kind of ignores the
high frequency features it look like a
cat right but these are unnatural
because the features in actual nature in
the real world they never occur in this
combination
so it seems like this is a very very
very different phenomenon from what I
would call natural ood ood data where
simply the the features that you're
seeing have never occurred in the
training data set but there is there is
if you go from the real world and you
construct in different ways data set
there is some data set where where the
where the data actually occurs in the
way that you have here so natural
already data is what most of the
examples for now were we're about like a
cow on the beach it's just because
you've never you've never seen that
because your data generation here always
good cow plus grass right so I think
these are very different and then the
last thing they also lump in here is
fairness like the the fairness and bias
literature where for example you have a
resume classifier and there is any
classifier ends up being biased by
gender or something like this and again
so I I kind of struggle with this
although they say not all the fairness
problems come from here but I would also
like to stress that some of the fairness
problem goes exactly here it occurs
because your data generation process is
different from what you want for example
if you do this this hiring classifier
you you have to understand what that is
what your training is a system that will
tell you how would my human data set
creators have decided on this particular
application now of course there is this
problem of bias amplification and so on
but it is not it is not an infallible
system it simply tells you how the
humans would predict and if you collect
the data set in a biased way of course
the the the machine will inherit that
but on the other hand the fairness why I
don't think this really belongs in here
because in fairness you have
a you actually have kind of an alternate
world draw this in green prime world
Prime right we're in this mode II and
III de setting you always assume that
the world is is the world and you want
to kind of really learn a system that
understands the world where in fairness
you this here this is your super world
so actually for the fairness literature
it doesn't really matter if in the real
world to let's say two groups of people
are equal in some respect or not equal
in the true world right what they care
about is that they are treated equally
by the system right so they will impose
they will impose some restrictions or
some some some condition on their model
and they don't they don't naturally
unlike this sounds bad but it is the
mathematical formulation is such that
you start with the super knowledge of
two things must be equal and then you
this is how you imagine your world you
think I know the world and then I try to
learn the model such that that happens
right whereas over here you do something
different now some of it is in as I said
is in the same category but it is I
think a different different take and a
different literature so I would I would
focus on let's say this part right here
sorry on this part and not on the
adversarial examples and also not in the
fairness literature too much alright so
yeah you can see here like like no
wonder this this and this screws up and
this screws up an image net classifier
yeah and even even this like how do we
know that that is naturally natural
though I can see that that is
that looks pretty natural but still it's
probably like really specifically
constructed such that the probability
that someone would take this picture
with a camera in the real world is zero
cool
so they give some examples where they
say okay shortcut learning exists in
computer vision for example adversarial
examples you see shifting the image by a
few pixels though you have to say
shifting the image very precisely by a
few pixels such that the probability of
this occurring the data generation
pipeline is zero and so on then they
call it domain transfer that that of
course is I think that's the that's a
good example
they say natural language processing
where Burt has been found to rely on
superficial cue words for instance it
learned within a data set of natural
language arguments detecting the
presence of anak was sufficient to
perform above chance in finding the
correct line of argumentation again this
is like all we can do is construct data
sets we cannot if we could tell the
model what to look at we would we would
we would just program the solution so
the solution is there's only one
solution program better data sets get
better data sets or I mean that ok the
second solution is get better inductive
biases but if we knew the correct
inductive biases we wouldn't have the
problem yeah I like that there is a in
NLP this is very this is very very
prevalent even more than in envision
right this this fact of hey these
Furious correlations in NLP the models
usually just learn kind of correlation
between some words and then they they
don't learn to understand the sentences
at all right but this this is because in
NLP we have even more
with constructing datasets that forced
the model to learn to understand the the
text again I can't not tell you what
understanding the text means they go in
by the way humans do that to humans most
in most of NLP that happens in humans
humans do this right in many many many
forms this assembly because the cost
function is not aligned with what you
would want
what is the specific oh well a specific
example is that news stories nowadays
right you have a news you say news what
do people attend expect what is the
intent of news the intent of news is to
inform you maybe but the cost right the
cost function is clicks so what do you
do you news story and very on the top in
the title you say orange man bad and
then people when you highlight this
right so a news story I don't know Brad
Pitt's had a new baby you just append
but orange man that people click on it
much more your cost goes up and sorry
your clicks go up your cost function
goes up and so I think this happens
everywhere right you can't even do this
with humans right how do you expect your
own networks to to do that all right
agent-based reinforcement learning I
think is pretty funny where is it where
it learned how to play Tetris yeah
instead of learning how to play Tetris
and algorithm simply learn to pause the
game to eclipse
come on is genius right like it is
objectively genius and then of course
fairness and algorithmic decision-making
right so they say understanding these
shortcuts and they they touch on a lot
of the things that I've touched on
including
these what I find what I find
well list for example this morgan scan
for machine learning where you say
probably a machine learning system will
learn the easiest feature it can and
that's oftentimes not what you want
right
so is this even now amplifies things
they also touch on this thing of
anthropomorphism where you view
everything through a human lens and that
is not correct if you look at these
neural networks they're not humans and
we should never attribute humaneness
to their solutions never attribute to
higher-level abilities that which can be
adequately explained by shortcut
learning yes I agree with this like I
agree with this paper in all the things
it says right except this detecting
shortcuts making OD generalization test
a standard practice for the reasons I
specified before I think that is
counterproductive and yeah I think I've
already said enough right designing good
OD tests this you can only design good
or detest if you know the real
underlying data distribution which you
don't and let's go three yeah again the
principle of least effort they say why
are they learned because it's just
easier right - it's just easier to write
a new story with just the words you know
people will click on right like are
these top ten things of blah blah blah
number seven will surprise you you don't
actually have to come up with ten
relevant things the entire title is
enough to get you the clicks so it's the
least effort to solve the cost function
might not align with what you want and
also the inductive biases as I said we
are humans we have some inductive biases
the neural networks don't have them and
we need to take this into account but
this
solution is to make training data sets
that take this into account all right
they say beyond your cut learning this
is kind of an outlook and then a
conclusion where they remind but we're
already at some 45 minutes of video and
if you're still here
like respect or maybe you just have this
in the background and Indian have some
company during this time I will finish
with saying thank you for watching and
leave your comments since this is mostly
opinion I would be interested in hearing
your comments on this with that I say
bye-bye